[Music]
if you've been paying any attention at
all to twitch lately you might have
asked yourself
why are so many people playing
old-school runescape
bro holy man holy bro there's no way bro
i thought i lost i'm dipping bro this is
a 20 year old mmo and
it's one of the most popular games on
the internet for some reason
it's pulling in thousands of viewers on
a daily basis
and most of them aren't watching for the
riveting gameplay
it's the one i only do at austria
sorry sorry oh [ __ ] but runescape has a
sequel
runescape three maybe eight years old
but it's a lot more recent and
way less ugly than the game you see
online all the time
so how did a 20 year old mmo outlive its
own sequel and become one of the pillars
of twitch
simple its developers nearly killed
their own game
in the early to mid 2000s runescape was
one of the most popular mmorpgs in the
world
but despite or maybe because of its
immense popularity
bots and gold farmers ran rampant over
runescape back then
a bot is a program that a player would
use
to run their runescape character for
them so when they're
away from their computer at work or at
college the bot can gather gold for them
or
fish for them or fight monsters for them
all sorts of simplistic activities that
the player would normally be doing
themselves they were in every world
stealing gold and resources from people
who were just trying to play the game
but according to runescape's developer
jagex that wasn't the only problem that
the game had
see it turns out that runescape had a
seedy underbelly of illegal fraudsters
really disturbingly for us we discovered
that there was all sorts of links
between gold farming and kind of other
illegal activities and
really quite dodgy parts of their
business going all over the world and we
were really really
fundamentally committed to stopping it
from happening in our game
alright before we go any further i
should explain a few things
the wilderness was a pvp area in
runescape back then
it was a place where players could go in
to fight against other players and the
winner in those fights would take gold
and a loot off the corpses they killed
the issue is that some players went into
the wilderness and died on purpose to
transfer their items to other players
here's how it worked
players would buy gold or items on shady
third party websites and then a gold
farmer would get those items
walk into the wilderness and get
themselves killed so the buyer could get
their goods
but gold farming and botting got so out
of hand that in 2007
jagex removed pvp combat from the
wilderness and restricted it to
mini-games like bounty hunter and clan
wars
before the changes the wilderness was
one of the most popular places in
gilinor
but afterwards it was barren see jagex
was trying to get rid of gold farming
and botting but what they really did was
kill pvp and the players were not happy
and then just one month later jagex
launched the unbalanced trade removal
update
players now had a trade limit of 10 000
coins every 15 minutes
while members had a maximum trade limit
of 60 000 coins
jagex was trying to combat scammers but
their decision had
unintended consequences free trade had
basically been removed from the game
entirely and longtime fans like
runescape youtuber kemku
felt betrayed so i had been pking for a
few months right before the free trade
removal update had been implemented and
just remember waking up
immediately trying to rush towards
edgeville wilderness ditch
and nobody was there it was completely
empty
players were so pissed off about all
this that they rioted in falador square
for an
entire week begging jagex to revert the
changes
the pay to pk riot also known as the
free trade riot ultimately resulted in
roughly 40
000 cancelled memberships which
translates to a little over 200
000 usd a month and for jagex that was a
huge problem
see you could always play runescape for
free but most players choose to pay for
a membership to unlock most of the
game's content
and back then jagex made most of their
money from memberships
they'd promised their community they
would never rely on microtransactions
the jagex probably lost a lot more money
because of people quitting the game like
if you ask anyone who plays runescape
nowadays
i think a lot of them have a very
similar story where they played as kids
and then stopped playing at the end of
2007 and then they found old school
later on and now they play old school a
few years later in 2012
jagex was facing real financial trouble
so
they caved they added microtransactions
to runescape
players could use real money to buy
cosmetics and other benefits but
longtime fans were worried after all
this was
exactly what jagex promised they would
never do
and then there was the infamous squeal
of fortune
at the time so it's like it was like a
little like scroll bar that would go
across the screen and land on the random
thing on there
and there's like the mega rare like in
the middle that was like some rare
weapon
or like 200 million gp or something at
the time as a kid being the young naive
kid i was i didn't understand
that it was like weighted differently i
thought oh there's like a one in 10
chance to roll that mega rare when in
reality it's probably one in like i
don't know a thousand or something but
just from what it looked on the screen
it's like oh dang i was so close to
hitting that
players could be awarded weapons armor
xp
lamps coins and more but it wasn't what
they wanted
the gambling devalued the hard work that
players put in grinding out for their
content
it may not be popular but it was very
necessary for
the fundamentally the financial
viability of jagex it's
[Music]
people may not think that's important
but if check is still around runescape's
not around
it's as simple as that more and more
players were leaving the game
on mass and jagex knew they had to do
something to stop the bleeding
jagex made a last-ditch effort to bring
runescape into the modern age with the
2012 evolution of combat update but
the fans hated it it seemed like jagex
had put the final nail in the coffin for
their own game
but then there was a petition
spearheaded by runescape youtubers so
wrecked that made them reconsider their
next move
so we'd re-engage with the community but
it was really clear
that they wanted one thing which was an
old version of runescape
we didn't know if this was even possible
but
we felt that we had to do it because we
had this huge community that was still
enjoying the game but we knew there was
this
old lapsed audience that had left
that we could win back if we were able
to provide them with an old version
okay so this next part is going to sound
crazy but
it's actually true someone found an old
hard drive in the back of a safe in the
jagex offices that
somehow had a build of runescape from
august
2007 still saved onto it the developers
once again reached out to their fans
asking if they'd be interested in
old-school servers
the response to the poll was
overwhelming
support players were excited and on
february 22nd
2013 old school runescape was officially
released to the public
nearly 40 000 players joined old school
runescape in the first month it was out
and
sure that number dropped over time as
the hype wore off but
old fans returned to the game of their
childhood and in march 2016
old school runescapes player numbers
surpassed runescape 3s for the first
time
ever and i don't think they ever really
planned for the game to
like actually be big or even grow bigger
than runescape 3
which i believe it is now with the
release of a mobile version of the game
in october 2017
the player base jumped from 58 000
players to
nearly a hundred thousand in the span of
just one month
and in march of 2020 old school
runescape hit its current record of 113
000 players uh you know now
we see numbers so much higher than
that you know at the time i wasn't even
looking at views
didn't even care for it at all but now
that i make youtube videos myself i can
see that
people in runescape these days get three
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
five hundred thousand
even up to millions of views on
runescape videos now
and it's crazy to think the amount of
growth that we've had
since old school came back to us
runescape was nearly at the brink of
extinction
but by listening to their fans and
admitting their mistakes the developers
were able to bring it back to
life these days jagex even does weekly
podcasts and regular polls that allow
players to vote on new content in the
overall direction of the game
this relationship between the developers
and the players is what's kept old
school runescape alive for so long
and why it's so damn popular on twitch
these days
and that's why this 20 year old game
continues to thrive
dumb decisions an old hard drive and a
legion of dedicated fans who just can't
get enough
we were in our middle school computer
lab and everybody played there were only
two games you played in that middle
school
computer lab you played age of empires
two or you played runescape
and i played age of empires too but my
friends all played runescape and they
were like you should play runescape with
us
so i did and then i immediately got all
my [ __ ] taken from me
instantly like oh i don't know what
happened i don't remember i just
remember like
we were like playing and then i got
killed and then i didn't have any stuff
anymore and now
there was a coin rolling across the
floor that probably sounded horrible on
the microphone